[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAE WANG: Good afternoon.
Let's get started.
As you think about
migrating to the cloud,
one of the first words that
often comes to your mind
is security.
Now, this week and
next you're going
to hear about
exciting technologies
on things like encryption
or DDoS prevention,
but at the center
of cloud security
there is a critical
element named people that
are the best security tools.
Technology is only
useful if you can
take control of
what a company owns,
how resources are provisioned,
and who has access to what.
And that is our topic today.
My name is Rae Wang.
I'm a product manager at Google.
You are also going
to meet a number
of other amazing speakers
throughout our session.
So cloud brings a
lot of benefits--
scale, availability, agility.
We all love building on cloud,
and that's why you are here.
When you move to the
cloud, it's not just
about moving your VMs from
one data center to another.
It is also the opportunity to
adopt the agile DevOps culture
and to transform into
a cloud based company.
You want to unleash
the developers
and let them run fast
with the scale of cloud.
But to do that with
a peace of mind,
you also want to put
in the guardrails
so that speed does not risk
security and compliance.
As you move from
on-premise to cloud,
the one thing you definitely
don't want to lose is control.
So what are some of the
common resource control
needs on cloud?
I want to share a
few stories that we
have heard from cloud admins.
One cloud admin
came to me and said,
back when things
were on-premise,
it was very easy for him to
account for all the assets
that his company owned.
So when he had to
build an inventory
to do scans or
audits, he was pretty
sure he included everything.
But on cloud it is a bit
of a different story,
because you have
many developers.
And one of them could just
pull out a credit card
to create a new
account, a new project,
and spin up a bunch
of VMs on cloud
without the admin knowing.
So what did this admin do?
Well, he ran a quarterly
cloud amnesty day
where his developers
were asked to come clean
with the newly created
projects and accounts
and grant him access so he could
include them in his inventory.
But even with that he
still wasn't really sure
he got them all.
Cloud gives us a
lot of flexibility.
You can choose from
many different types
of VMs, different VM images,
many different services.
But just like in real life, we
know that more choices is not
always better.
In a company, often
standardization
is what's required to
meet compliance needs,
or reduce security
risks, or even
to optimize test investment.
So our challenge is
how to standardize
resource configurations
on the ever more
flexible public cloud.
Another hot topic lately,
you probably have heard,
is data exfiltration.
In the last few years, there
has been no shortage of news
on companies accidentally
leaking sensitive customer
data.
On one hand, cloud eliminates
one of the key risks,
which is leaking data
via physical device,
because you simply cannot
take a USB key and plug
into the cloud.
On the other hand, though,
now how you access resources
is through cloud API endpoints.
And these are APIs that
are publicly documented
and everybody can
attempt to access them.
Therefore, your main line of
defense is now access policies.
Therefore, the principle
of least privilege
is more important than ever.
Next, we're going to
look at how the GCP
tools will help you to take
control of your resources.
So first we're going
to talk about IAM.
IAM stands for identity
and access management.
It allows you to define
a policy that says who
can do what on which resources.
The can do what part is
defined by an IAM role which
is a group of permissions.
To do a meaningful
job, for example,
if you want to let somebody
manage your GC resources,
it takes more than
just a single command.
They need to be able
to create and delete,
and start and stop, and do a
bunch of things to the VMs.
So we group them
together as an IAM role.
Now, in the example
here, you can
see we're granting the
Compute Instance Admin
role to a number of
users on our project.
That allows these users to
be able to go in and manage
all the GC instances
in that project.
So we first launched IAM
last year at GCP Next,
and since then we have shipped
many more predefined roles.
We're now at over
60 roles across most
of our major services.
By using these roles instead
of the primitive owner, editor,
and viewers, you can grant
more granular permissions.
For example, if you want to
give your developers permissions
to look at logs so
they can do debugging,
but you don't really want
them to poke around the PI
data on your GCS buckets, you
can grant them a log viewer
role on project so that the only
thing they can use in a project
is logs.
Now, I can grant these roles on
projects or organization, which
we will talk about
a little later.
In some cases, you
can also grant them
on individual
resources-- for example,
on GCS buckets or
BigQuery data sets.
The top question we got after
last year's launch after
our 20-something
pre-defined roles was--
can I create my
own custom roles?
Even at 60 roles, we still
have customers who come to us
and go, I just need to
tweak that a little bit.
Can I have my own custom roles?
Today we're happy to announce
that IAM Custom Roles has
launched to a
public alpha, which
means you can go to the doc site
and sign up to be whitelisted.
You can create custom roles
by either grouping together
a set of permissions or
by modifying one or more
of the existing roles.
For example, if in
your company you
want to let your developers
manage GCE instances,
but you don't want them
to open up external IPs,
you can create a
more restrictive role
by taking the
instance admin role
and removing the permission
to create external IP.
Or maybe you have a service
account whose sole job
is to attach PDs to VMs.
They can create
a very small role
with just that permission
for a service account.
Custom roles can be
created at a project level
to be used by
application on your team,
or they can also be created
at the organization level
and then all the developers
and all the projects
in your company can
access the same roles.
Since the I in IAM
stands for identity
I want to mention it here,
even though we're not
going to go into details,
because it's covered
by a couple of other sessions.
Yesterday there was a session on
Google's Identity as a Service
that talks about how to manage
users, groups and federations.
If you missed it, don't
worry, the recording
will be on YouTube
in a few days.
And tomorrow there is going
to be a session on the best
practice of managing IAM
for GCE during which we're
going to go into depth about
how to secure your service
accounts.
So we talked about
the permissions.
Well, these permissions
are assigned on resources.
So it's important to
talk about how resources
are defined and grouped on GCP.
What you're looking at here
is a resource hierarchy.
Because we know that they're not
just a flat list of VMs and GCS
buckets, we don't want to
manage them one by one,
so we want to group
them together.
Now, if you're already
a GCP customer,
you're probably familiar
with the concept
of a project, which is this
yellow layer in the tree.
A project is a basic
resource container for GCP,
and it's also a policy unit.
On the top of the tree, the blue
layer-- that's the organization
node which we also
launched last year.
This is your company's
root node for managing
all of your GCP resources.
Now, since then we have
added the red layers
in the middle called folders.
Because many of you
came to us and said,
well, my company
is large, we have
multiple independent divisions,
branches, departments,
and we want to manage
them differently.
So we have added
these layers so we
can model your departments,
your organizations
within organizations.
IAM policies are
inherited from top
down in this resource hierarchy.
If you have the admin permission
on the organization node
that gives you admin permission
into all the folders, projects,
and resources in
your organization.
At any of the nodes,
the permission
that you get on a resource is a
combination of the permissions
that are directly
assigned to the resource
as well as all the inherited
permissions from its ancestors.
The reason we do that
is so that it's not
possible for a resource
owner to lock out
a central admin who is granted
permissions on a high level.
So let's look at organization
node a little bit more.
Organization node, as we
said, is the root node
of your GCP resources.
So all of your other
projects, folders, resources,
can belong to your
organization node.
One recent addition is
the billing account.
So now billing
accounts can also be
moved underneath your
organization node
and get the same
inherited IAM permissions.
If you have multiple
billing accounts,
all you need to do is to
assign your billing admin team
the billing admin role once
on the organization level,
and that gives them access
to all the billing accounts
underneath the organization.
The organization node is
linked to your G Suite domain.
That allows us to enforce
the ownership policy which
says, if any identity
in your company
goes and creates
a new project, it
will automatically belong
to your organization node.
You don't have to
do any extra work.
It will just being enforced.
It prevents shadow
projects, rogue admins,
you can't have projects
created without you
knowing or having visibility.
The number of organization-wide
management tasks
have also become easier
with the org node.
For example, as an admin you
can control who in your company
is or is not allowed
to create resources
by carefully assigning
the project creator role.
You can also now find
and build inventory--
you remember at the beginning
of the talk we talked about
the admin not knowing
inventory-- now
you can build it by
programmatically enumerating
through the projects and
the folders' projects
and resources underneath
the organization node.
Another common practice is
to have a service account
with org level permission to
do the company-wide config
monitoring and enforcement.
And that is in fact what
our Google's own security
team does.
Folders, as we said,
are organizations
within organizations.
So all of these
management benefits
can also be done at a folder
level for your department
admins.
One new thing we want to
announce that we have recently
added to the organization node
is the organization policy.
We talked about
flexibility and the need
to standardize configurations.
Well, the organization policy
allows you to do exactly that.
You can define the org policy
on the organization node.
It will get inherited into
other projects and resources
underneath.
You can also make exceptions
on a per project basis,
but even the exceptions are
controlled by the org-level
policy admin so that project
owners cannot just create
a loophole for themselves.
Now, what's different
from the IAM policy
is that the IAM policy
distinguishes different users
with different permissions.
Whereas the org policies are
assigned on resources and they
apply to all the users who
access the resource, including
a project owner.
Let's look at one
of the policies
in a little more detail.
This is the Allowed
Services policy.
What this policy
allows you to do
is inside a project you can go
and enable many different APIs
representing different services
that you can use in a project.
This policy allows the
central admin to say,
here are the only
allowed services
that can be enabled in
a company's projects.
In this example
here, the admin says,
I'm only allowing two services
to be used in our projects.
Now, you can do this either
for compliance reasons
or you can do this for
cost control reasons.
This policy then gets
inherited into our projects.
And then when a
developer attempts
to enable a service that's
not allowed by the policy,
they would get a
clear error message
indicating that this is
prevented by the org admin.
Now, they have a couple
of projects where
you need to make exceptions.
So Project A is a more
sensitive, critical application
that needs to have a
more restrictive policy.
The admin sets the
exception to say,
I'm going to replace
the inherited policy
by a new policy that's
more restrictive that
only allows a single service.
Project B is a test
environment, where
you test out new services
before you release them
to your developers.
So in Project B, the
exception that's set
says, let's inherit
the parents' policy,
but also augment it by
adding two other services
so Project B can use up
to four services now.
We went through, you
saw many different IAM
roles, different
types of policies,
and you also have a lot of
users, a lot of resources.
And we all know
managing those manually
quickly becomes unscalable.
We wanted to go
home for the weekend
and have dinner with our family.
So automation and
templatization is
going to be very key to
your management experience.
We all know that
the way to deploy
an application, or
deploy a VM, is not
by manually clicking buttons.
You want to templatize them
to avoid unique snowflakes.
And now the same can be done
with project provisioning.
In a company, it's
typical that there
are a set of centrally defined
configurations for projects,
such as how they should be
named, which APIs are enabled,
which billing account
to use, and the default
IAM networking policies.
You want to set these
configurations once centrally.
And then developers, as
they spin up new projects,
don't have to go and think
about it every single time.
Now all the APIs
for these key steps
are available in the public.
You can write your
program, your script,
to program against these APIs.
You can also wrap up your
configuration into a template
and have Deployment Manager
drive the automation for you.
So now that you have
your resources deployed,
you still want to know what's
going on in production.
You don't want to fly blind.
And you can leverage
the autologs
to keep an eye on what's going
on in the production system.
The admin logs now capture all
the policy changes, including
IAM networking and so on.
So there are a couple of
things you can do with that.
One is you can use Stackdriver
log-based metric to,
for example, set up a
metric on the event org dot
set time policy.
And then you can set up an alert
in Stackdriver on that metric,
so that every time the org
level IAM policy is changed,
you get notified.
You get alerted for that.
You can also export your
audit logs into Pub/Sub
and then use Pub/Sub to
trigger Cloud Functions.
Cloud Functions
is a product that
allows you to define if this,
then that type of rules.
So if you want to
prevent an identity
outside of your company from
being added to your company's
IAM policies, you can define a
rule to look for that pattern
and then trigger the action
to revert the policy change.
We also have data access
logs which capture
all the data access records.
So every time you use access
data it will be captured.
You can export the data
access logs into BigQuery.
Then using BigQuery you
can answer questions
such as when was the last time
person X accessed resource Y,
and this allows you
to do two things.
One is if there are
unexpected access patterns,
a user shouldn't have access to
something, you can catch that
and then you can
figure out where
you need to fix their policy.
Or alternatively,
you can find out
that certain policies are
just not getting exercised.
Person X could
access resource Y,
but they haven't
done it for years,
so it's time to
retire that policy.
OK.
So we just went through
the building blocks.
You heard about the different
APIs and tools and policies.
Now let's put them
together end to end and do
a few policy design exercises
for a few companies.
You can see that by
using the same tools
and the same policies
configured differently,
you can build
resource management
systems for companies with
very different priorities
and cultures.
First, we're going to talk
about a traditional enterprise.
A traditional enterprise likely
has existed and succeeded
in industry for quite a
while, so they have built up
a sophisticated
organization structure
because of growth and because
of mergers, acquisitions.
They tend to care a lot
about security, compliance,
and separation of duty.
They also tend to
have a lot of existing
tools and internal systems,
and even on-premise departments
that the cloud deployment
needs to be able to fit in.
So this is an example design
for a traditional enterprise.
The identities can be centrally
managed in their existing LDAP
services, and then
these identities
can be fed right into Google
via the Identity Sync.
An organization
node is provisioned
on top linked with
the entity domain,
so that you can have full
visibility and control
of the company's resources.
For a traditional enterprise,
procurement decisions
are often made at
organizational level,
and the creation and
changing of resources
are done centrally
by existing tools,
perhaps through a
service account.
Therefore, developers
don't really
need permissions to go and
create or change resources.
They can request those to
be done through an existing
workflow.
Folders are created, as we
talked about, your model, maybe
your different
international branches
or different independent groups.
They can be used to grant
these different divisions,
different policies, as well as
a way to do cost aggregation.
One other practice that
we have commonly seen
is to pre-create groups
for all the major IAM roles
that you want to use at your
project and folder level.
And then post the
initial provisioning,
you can even drive all of
your IAM policy changes
throughout our system.
So that was the
traditional enterprise.
Now let's go to the other side,
which is a very Agile Dev/Ops
company.
So in the Agile Dev/Ops
team, the priority
is often to optimize for
team autonomy and velocity.
You want to let your
developers run fast,
and your developers are trusted
to make their own decisions
on what tools to use and how
to deploy and monitor the apps.
But like we said,
the admin still
wants to set in some guardrails
so that the developers are
still operating within
the bounds of security
and compliance.
Here, underneath the
organization node,
you can provision a folder for
different teams' departments.
What's different here is that
these teams and departments
fully own all the resources and
how to deploy and manage them
underneath their folders.
Of course, there are some
centrally shared infrastructure
resources that don't belong
to these individual teams,
such as your cross-product
project networks or Stackdriver
accounts.
So those can be curated in
shared infrastructure projects
or folders and only managed
by your central networking
or security teams.
Here it seems the developers
get to do their own things
and make their own choices.
The admin has set the
organization-wide org policies
to set those guardrails, so that
only the blessed config options
are available to the
developers when they choose
to deploy their applications.
The service account that
has org-wide permission
takes a slightly
less active role
and no longer is in the critical
path to deploy applications
for developers, but instead
it does org-wide aggregation
and monitoring.
A third type of company
that we commonly see
is an education or
a training company.
In such an organization,
the training owner usually
owns the billing
account and all the cost
that's associated
with running the labs.
Isolation between
both the users,
and between the users and
lab owners, is very critical.
The entire provisioning
process needs
to be fully automated end to end
so it can be fast and scalable.
In this case, the lab owner
can use a G Suite domain
to host the identities
of the lab users
and use the org node and folders
to host the resources used
for the labs.
For every new session,
a temporary user ID
can be created and approached
[AUDIO OUT] correspondingly.
The user's activities are fully
contained within the project
and that creates isolation.
And at the end of
the session, it's
very easy to just wipe out
both the project and the user.
One thing that a lot of lab
owners are very concerned about
is abuse.
Because when you're
paying for those VMs,
you certainly do not
want people to be using
them to do Bitcoin mining.
So there are a few
ways to help you
to address the abuse concern.
One is that projects
come with default quotas.
So unless you raise
them, the defaults
are set low enough to prevent
a user from spinning up
a large amount of resources
to abuse your resources.
You can also set
organization policy,
as we talk about the
allowed services policy,
to restrict every lab to
only be able to enable
the necessary
services for the labs.
And then the identity
domain allows the admin
to have the last say here,
because only the admin,
not the users, can
control the identities.
So if the admin comes in
and disables or deletes
an identity, that immediately
removes all the access
that a user can have
to these resources.
And since the user can't
come back and change
it back there won't
be any race condition,
the admin has the last say.
How many have you have tried
the security boot camps?
Raise of hand.
A few.
So the security boot
camps were actually
built on this architecture.
They were built by this
company called Qwiklabs,
who is a training company
and also a recent Google
acquisition.
So if you need to
provide courses
in labs in the
future on GCP, you
can either use Qwiklabs
as the platform
or use this reference
architecture.
So we have just said that using
the same tools and policies
configured differently,
you can cater
to three very
different companies
with different
priorities and culture.
Next, let's invite
on stage my colleague
Ray Colline to
show you the demos.
[APPLAUSE]
RAY COLLINE: All
right, thank you Rae.
I'm actually Ray Colline,
a software engineer
who's worked a lot on the
organizations and folders
products.
In this demo, we
are going to show
how a hypothetical
G-twix corporation can
use GCP to lower their costs
and gain a competitive advantage
in the candy bar industry.
Let's explore how they
can use the flexibility
of this hierarchy to organize
and gain control over their GCP
resources.
To produce the two different
bars in every package,
the G-twix corporation has
organized themselves into two
divisions--
left G-twix and right G-twix.
These two divisions have very
different corporate cultures
and requirements.
We will show you how you
can use the GCP resource
hierarchy, IAM policies.
G Suite groups, and
service accounts
to support a configuration that
uses policy scanners, audit
logging, organization policies,
and project templating to gain
control over their resources.
Now, here is the
Manage Resources page
within the Cloud
Console, where we
can get an overview of
the G-twix GCP hierarchy.
Now, note, I will only be
showing the resource hierarchy
and their associated
IAM policies that enable
all of these configurations.
Now, looking at the
top level folder,
we see that there's
an organization
node and two folders.
The first folder is for their
IT team and the second folder
is for all of the
different product teams.
Now, within the IT folder
we have four projects.
One is the service account
container for centralization
of service account management.
The second is an
IT security scanner
where you can run the
open source IAM policy
scanner and some
homegrown tools to ensure
that the configuration of
all the resources is correct.
The third is an IT
project templating project
where all of the templates that
ensure standard configurations
are contained and where
they get provisioned.
And fourth is an XPN
host network where
all of G-twix's networks live.
Now let's look at Left G-twix.
There, central control is a core
requirement to their business.
They value standardization to
lower costs, increase security
and reliability, and to
minimize the variations that
need to be evaluated against
their compliance regimes.
In fact, Left G-twix
finds themselves
under PCI compliance.
We will now show you
their IAM policies folders
and project set up.
So first, we can see on
their divisional folder
that in the viewer role there is
the IT security scanner service
account.
This is inherited
from the org node
and this gives the
ability for the security
scanner to see every
resource within the Left
G-twix division.
Secondly, we'll see that both
for folder creator and project
creator the G-twix provisioning
system is the only one allowed
to create folders and projects.
This guarantees that they
use the standard setups that
are prescribed by
their requirements.
When we go into the
folder we'll see that they
have three different projects.
They have a dev, test,
and prod project.
Now, the dev and test projects
are set up very similarly.
For the dev projects, we
will see that the owner
is the provisioner.
What this means is they
used a templating system
to set up this project
to keep it standard.
They've given the
G Suite group that
represents their dev team the
ability to have editor rights.
Now, editor is a
fairly broad role,
and this is generally OK
because their dev and test
projects do not have
customer or revenue data.
Now, when we look at
the production project,
we will see that the owner is
still the provisioning robot.
In fact, the dev and
test and prod projects
have the identical setup,
because they were provisioned
with the same template.
But the editor access is
only given to the current SRE
on-call.
We can imagine that on-premise
G-twix has an Active Directory
system that's hooked up
with some group workflows,
and they use calendar based
and time of day based rules
for putting people into groups.
And then those groups are then
synced using the identity sync
features of G Suite to
push them into G Suite
so we can use them here.
And so this means that only
the current on-call is actually
given access to this group.
Secondly, we'll see a
few limited curated roles
that we give to people
with prod access, which
is another similar one
of these managed groups,
and we employ the principle
of least privilege
which is required
by PCI compliance.
So let's review left G-twix.
One, we prevent
users from creating
projects and other resources
to avoid snowflake setups
and loss of control.
Two, we employ the
principle of least privilege
required by PCI and
other compliance regimes.
Three, we use group
memberships on IAM policies
and use workflow and
group integrations
to control memberships.
And four, we use different
policies for production and dev
projects.
So let's talk
about Right G-twix.
They have a completely
different set of requirements
for their use of GCP.
They wish to run fast and loose
to give room for innovation.
They value independence
and the ability for teams
to choose the best solutions
to fit their needs.
Fortunately for Right
G-twix, they're not
under any compliance regimes.
However, the G-twix
IT department
wants to ensure that they
have sufficient guardrails
around their usage
to keep things safe.
I will now show you the
Right G-twix organization.
In their divisional
folder, we will
see that again the IT
security scanner, inherited
through the org node,
has viewer access
and therefore can look at
all of the configurations
and resources across
their division.
Two, that in the folder creator
and project creator roles,
their entire team group is able
to create projects and folders.
Three, we let them have folder
viewer access so they can
see their colleagues' folders.
Now, going in here, we
will see that there's
an experimental project.
This experimental
project was created
by one of their
engineers, Jenna Wu, who's
working on their next
generation system.
And we'll note that she
has owner on this project,
and this lets her invite her
colleagues as she sees fit.
We'll also notice when we
look at their dev project
that the owner is not
the provisioner robot
but instead is their dev
team, because at Right G-twix
they allow for homegrown scripts
and for one-off setups, again,
to fit their needs.
So let's review right G-twix.
One, they allow
anyone in their org
to create folders and projects.
Two, even with the
looser configuration,
they still lock down
their production product
to SRE and those
who need to know.
Three, they encourage
innovation by allowing
experimental projects.
And four, the G-twix IT team
uses the IT security scanner
to ensure that Right
G-twix does not
have any large vulnerabilities
or other types of security
issues.
Overall, we have
seen how G-twix IT
has been able to use the
organization, folders, IAM,
and groups and service accounts
to configure their resources
to fit their unique needs.
If you're curious about
project templating,
service accounts, organization
policies, group management
and policy scanning, please
see us at the PM sandbox
afterwards.
It's great that we reviewed
this hypothetical organization,
but now we bring on stage
Lukas Karlsson from the Broad
Institute to give a
real world example
of how they organize their GCP
resource hierarchy to achieve
their organization's needs.
Thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
LUKAS KARLSSON:
I'm Lukas Karlsson
from the Broad Institute.
I'm the cloud
architect and developer
advocate at the Broad.
The Broad is a
nonprofit genomics
and biomedical
research center located
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
I started there in 2003, just
after they completed the Human
Genome Project.
At the time, we were called
the Whitehead Institute
Center for Genome Research.
The Broad itself
was founded in 2004.
And you may have
heard of us, if you
hadn't heard of the
Human Genome Project,
you may have heard of us
more recently in regards
to our patent for the
CRISPR/Cas9 system for editing
genes.
The Broad gets it's funding
from a variety of sources.
For example,
philanthropic donations,
federal government grants
from the National Institutes
of Health and the National
Cancer Institutes,
collaborations and partnerships
with industry, and technology
licensing opportunities.
Each of these funding sources
for us translates internally
into something
called a cost object.
We use these cost objects to
pay for the services, materials,
and staff that
support the research.
Cost objects, for us,
have very specific rules
about how they can be used.
Before you can use your cost
object to pay for GCP services,
you need to go through a
complicated approval process.
You have to work with
your grant's administrator
to determine if the grant can
support the volume of spend
that you're looking to
do and to understand
how long the grant is
available and whether it's even
allowed to be used for
cloud computing services.
Once you've received
approval for using your cost
object in the cloud, we will
create a billing account
for you.
Broad is set up similar
to a GCP reseller
in that we have one
master billing account,
and we receive a monthly
invoice from Google for that.
We have dozens and
dozens of things
called sub accounts which sit
underneath the master billing
account.
Each of these
sub-accounts for us
corresponds to one of our
internal cost objects,
and we have about
75 of them today.
We're also a G Suite customer
and have been since 2010.
Over the years, we've
actually accumulated more
than one G Suite
domain, so we actually
have multiple organization
resource nodes as well.
We use the IAM
folders functionality
to organize our folders
and to grant permissions
to the projects.
We map the folder structure
very similar to how
we map the actual organization.
So in the example you see
here, the IT department
has two organizations beneath
it, engagement and operations,
each of which have a folder.
They collect all of their
projects in that folder.
In general, the person who is
the leader of that organization
is the folder administrator
on that folder.
They can control
whether projects
get put into the folder or
whether other folders can be
created underneath that folder.
We apply a number of
organization policies
at our org node
at the top level.
For example, we're rather
open about project creation.
So everyone in the Institute
is able to create projects,
but we're very strict
about how money gets spent.
So no one is allowed to
enable billing on projects,
except for specific
people who are
billing account administrators.
The billing accounts that
we have, all 75 of them,
are in our org node as well.
So we're able to apply the
billing account creator
and billing account
administrator
and a few other positions
at the org level,
so that someone in our
procurement department
can oversee all of
the billing accounts
that exist and can end them
when a grant has ended.
We also have some
folks in IT who
oversee administration
of all of the projects,
and so they have
owner level access.
And then, as has been
described a few times,
we have a service account
that can read everything.
That allows us to do
automation and security
scans, and so forth.
We use project labels
to some extent.
Initially, we were using them
to track which cost object.
But when we moved to the
billing account model,
we've stopped doing that.
We use them to track which
environment a project
is associated with.
And now that resource
labels are available,
we've started using those
on some of our resources
to track how much a particular
workflow might cost.
So provisioning
projects in this model
can be quite time consuming.
I have one example that Rae and
I have discussed repeatedly.
A couple of years ago,
a year or two ago,
I had to create 50
projects for a workshop
where each person would
have their own project.
And so to do so, I
opened 50 browser tabs,
and I clicked create
project 50 times.
Then I proceeded to follow
all the steps that I have here
on this screen.
So for each one I
had to enable billing
to the appropriate
billing account.
For each one I had to enable
a handful of API services
in the API console,
some of which
you click and wait
for the service
to enable before you can
click and enable the next one.
We had to set about half a dozen
IAM policies on each project
so that the right users
could administer the project
and the right service
accounts could
interact with the project.
And again, we had
project labels.
These projects were
all compute projects,
so we had to enable the compute
usage export for each of them.
Now, a new thing we do
today is set the default
compute region and zone.
This was a very painful
process, and this is actually
something--
I was doing this manually
in advance to the workshop.
But the application
that we built
on Google Cloud,
called firecloud.org,
it has to do this as
part of the service.
So there's no way that the
application can expect a person
to go perform all these tasks.
So we've automated this--
initially we automated it in
Python using a simple script.
Now this is the
same functionality
that is built into
our Java application
as part of our cloud service.
So real quick, I'm going to
talk about the Python tool
that I've made to do this.
It's open source.
It's available on GitHub.
My username is L-U-K-W-A-M, and
I think it might be the only
thing there currently.
It currently uses the
application default
credentials, so it's very
easy to just run it right
after you do the git clone.
You don't really need
to do anything special,
especially if you are
on Google Cloud Shell
and you already have all
of the resources installed.
I currently am using a YAML
file to configure templates.
For any type of project
I want to create,
I can create a
YAML file that has
all of the desirable
settings for that project.
Here's an example
of how it would run.
You basically run the
command and then specify
which template you
would like to use,
and you have a folder where
you store all your templates.
In an upcoming
version it will also
look for templates
in a GCS bucket.
If you wish, you can also
avoid using the template
or you can override settings in
your template with the command
line options.
If your template puts
all your projects
in a particular folder,
but for this one
you want this project to
be in a different folder,
you can specify that
at the command line.
And real quick, I'm
just going to go
through what the
various options are
that are currently supported.
Upon project creation, you
can either automatically
set the parent to your org node
or to one of your folder nodes
using the Cloud
Resource Manager API.
It enables a billing account to
the specified billing account.
As I said we have 75
of them, so depending
on what you're creating
you have to know which
billing account to put it in.
It sets whatever
desirable IAM policies
on the project using the
Resource Manager API.
It enables each API service,
like compute and storage,
or whatever is needed for
your particular situation,
using the Service
Management API.
It can put project labels
on the project which
we'll use, for example, if
we have three projects where
one is dev, and one is
test, and one is production.
You can put an
environment label on there
to tell which is which.
It will create service
accounts using the IAM API,
and it can also create keys
and download those keys.
And it can set some
default compute settings.
If you specify a compute usage
bucket that doesn't exist,
it will create the bucket in
GCS first and then set that
as your compute usage bucket.
If it does exist,
then it won't bother.
Here is an example
of it running.
And then real quick
I'm actually going
to attempt to do this
live for everybody.
So if we could switch
to the computer.
Here is the Git Repo
that I mentioned.
Here is a very simple
template, which
literally just sets the
appropriate billing account.
It sets my super admin
account as the owner,
and it sets the Google group,
DevOps at Broad, as an editor.
It puts a label on it, which is
the former way we used to track
cost objects across projects.
And it sets a folder,
which is the DevOps
folder within my organization.
So real quick I will just
run an example of this.
The first thing it
does is print out
the template
describing what it is
going to do that shows which
billing account, which folder,
and which policy and
labels are going to be set.
It has created the project.
It has set the IAM
policy, enabled billing,
and created labels.
And there's a link
right here that if I
want to load up the
project on my browser just
to make sure it did the
right thing, I can do that.
Boom, the project created.
One other example I will
show just so everyone
can feel the pain
of the provisioning
process for Firecloud.
This is the template
for Firecloud.
We had about 15 different
APIs we had to enable.
We had nine different
IAM bindings
that we had to add in there.
We had to create three different
service accounts and so forth.
So now all of this can be
done with a single command
line where I specify
the names of all
50 projects and the
template that I want to use,
and then I walk away and
it does it automatically.
And that's the end of my demo.
Back to Rae.
[APPLAUSE]
RAE WANG: Can we switch
back to slides, please?
Thank you, Lukas, for
telling us Broad's story
and also for sharing your
project provisioning tool.
We know that admins
and developers
love to create and share
tools and want to leverage
the open source ecosystem.
So now let's look at
some of the open source
tools you can use to
manage GCP policies.
Google has a legendary
security team,
and they have created an
internal tool set for managing
Google's own GCP usage.
Now, I want to share the same
learning and same capabilities
without GCP customers, so
we're happy to announce
that we have just launched
the Forseti Security
Toolset to GitHub.
Forseti is the god of
justice and reconciliation,
and the Forseti Toolset
can help you to watch over
your GCP policies.
In this first launch, we have
included an inventory tool
that builds, creates, and stores
an inventory for organizations
starting from your projects
in the IAM policies.
The policy scanner
detects policy violation
between ideal and actual states,
and the enforcer will centrally
manage and apply
changes to your policies
starting from your
GC firewall rules.
Now you can use these
tools as building blocks
to build your automation
systems both for GCP
and for on-premise.
And we also want to
invite all of you
to contribute and share
your tools with us.
And one of our first
contributors is Spotify.
Spotify has a very similar
problem as the Google admin
team, which is they
have many projects,
and they also have
security policies
that they want to make sure
that developers follow.
They are very excited to
contribute and to help
us to grow the
community and accelerate
the development of the
tools that we can all use.
We also have a
survey here that you
can use to tell us what
additional open source tools
you want us to add to Forseti.
OK.
So we're going to build
brand new tools to help
you to do your job on GCP.
We also want to make
sure that if you
have tools that you
already know and love,
you can also use them on GCP.
And one of these tools
is the Security Monkey.
The Security Monkey
was built and released
by Netflix in 2014.
It does continuous scanning and
analysis of your policy changes
and alerts you on
risky patterns.
We recently added integration
for IAM GCS networking
so that now you can leverage
the power of Security Monkey
for your GCP resources as well.
A few minutes ago
we talked about how
to use either the
APIs or deployment
managers to provision
your projects,
and that works great on GCP.
But I know that some
of you also have
to manage the resources not
only on a single platform,
but cross multiple clouds or
between cloud and on prem,
and you want to have
a single tool that
can work seamlessly across
these different platforms.
And for that reason we
recently added the provisioning
capability into TerraForm,
which is a popular multi-cloud
config management system.
So now I want to welcome on
stage Seth Vargo from HashiCorp
to show us how to provision
a GCP application end
to end using TerraForm.
[APPLAUSE]
SETH VARGO: Great.
Thank you, Rae.
Hi, everyone.
He was first.
All right, let's
talk about TerraForm.
How many people here have
heard of TerraForm before?
Awesome.
So TerraForm is a completely
free and open source tool.
You can go download
it right now.
It lives on GitHub, built by
the folks over at HashiCorp.
That's where I work.
And we're here today.
If you want to come say hi or
you want to ask any questions,
stop over by Charlie six.
We'll be there all
day and tomorrow.
TerraForm is designed,
like Rae said,
for those
multi-cloud/hybrid-cloud
situations.
So it's very rare today to
have all of your resources
in one cloud,
especially if you're
a company that's been around
the block for a while.
You probably have some
on-premise infrastructure.
You probably have some stuff
in those other cloud providers.
You probably have
some stuff in Google.
And you really need
a way to describe
all of those
infrastructure resources.
What TerraForm
does is it provides
a single configuration
file format,
a text file, that allows you to
describe all of those resources
across multiple clouds and
other things like top level DNS.
Maybe you're using
a third party DNS
provider or DDoS mitigation, and
you need to codify all of that
into a file.
And when we put that into a
file, what we get is theft.
We get to steal everything that
application developers have
had for years and apply
it to infrastructure.
Because application engineers
have these great things.
They have CI.
They have CD.
They have linting.
They have testing--
that when you're just
running shell
commands, you don't
get that same level
of automation,
that same level of testing.
So TerraForm enables things like
testing, automation, project
stamping.
You get VCS and
GitHub integration.
You can keep track of history
of all of your resources
across the infrastructure.
And because TerraForm has
a common state format,
you can build APIs and
automation around that.
So what are some use cases here?
Well, many people run in
multiple environments.
You have dev, you have prod,
you have QA, you have staging.
And how many people here have
a long running QA environment
that costs them thousands
of dollars a month?
Yeah.
And how many people here
never use that environment?
It's just sitting there
wasting resources?
Or you have the
opposite problem.
Maybe you have this one
dedicated QA environment,
but all of your developers are
queued up, waiting for changes,
waiting to get
approval, and they're
sitting in a large queue and
you're wasting resources.
TerraForm can actually solve
both of these problems.
Because TerraForm builds
a graph of your resources
in these configuration
formats, it
can quickly stamp out entire
environments, sometimes
in less than five minutes.
So instead of having this
long running QA environment
that's costing you thousands
of dollars a month,
just spin one up.
In the amount of time
it takes your developer
to walk to the water
cooler and back, they
could have a full development
environment ready to go.
Send the URL off to the
QA team, the QA team
stamps it, you destroy the
project, maybe it cost you $25.
And this can all be
done in parallel.
If you have multiple
QA engineers,
you can have multiple
people approving deployments
and they can go out in parallel.
So it really ties into those
DevOps and Agile practices.
The same thing can be
applied for things like CI
and project stamping.
Maybe you're an IT
team and you need
to give different organizations
exactly the same thing
over and over and over again.
But it's multi-cloud.
How would you do that?
Well, with TerraForm you
define the configurations,
you change one or
two attributes,
and you can very
quickly stamp out
different projects for different
teams in the organization.
And lastly, continuous
integration.
Everyone loves Jenkins.
It's one of the most
popular CI tools.
But we tend to have these really
long running CI environments,
and they gradually become
snowflakes over time.
Or we have different tools
installed and different
plug-ins and widgets,
and we run them overnight
even though we don't have
any CI running overnight.
So we're paying for
them to live on forever.
With TerraForm you
can codify those.
You can quickly scale them
up, quickly scale them down,
and turn them off overnight.
So you're not paying for
those unused resources.
So I want to quickly
go through an example
here for project templating.
The best way to
think about this is
some of the previous
examples we saw
where you have training
environments or isolated
projects that you
want to create.
This is the workflow
you saw before.
If you were doing this in
the UI or through the API,
you'd have to create a project.
You'd have to enable
billing on that object,
then enable the APIs, optionally
create service accounts,
set IAM policies-- that same
workflow that Lukas talked
about that involves
clicking buttons--
and it's relatively
painful to do manually.
Thankfully, Google
has a number of APIs
and TerraForm
consumes those APIs.
So this is an example
TerraForm configuration.
And just like whenever
you need to talk
to Google's API with cURL
or with the command line,
you have to give it
your credentials.
It can consume the local
G Cloud credentials
or you can provide them
via an account file.
So here we're just
telling TerraForm
how to talk to Google.
Next, we have to define
what's called a project.
This can be created
multiple times,
so this is creating
a project that's
named terraform-demo-123456.
I'm attaching it to
a billing account,
and then I'm putting it
inside my organization.
And I'm just giving it the
human-friendly label of demo.
I could create
multiple projects.
I could put this piece
of code multiple times
on the same slide to
create multiple projects.
Or I could use a count
attribute to create
10 projects all at once.
Within that project I then
have to enable services.
By default, if you haven't
configured the org node
when you create a project, it
doesn't have any APIs enabled.
So we can use the Google
project resource--
Google project services
resource, to enable services
on that project.
The project is the name of
the project I just created,
and then here I'm enabling IAM
and the Cloud Resource Manager
APIs.
Then we can optionally
create a service account.
So that service
account here is going
to be created
inside that project.
I'm giving it a human-friendly
name of demo service account,
and I'm attaching
it to my account.
This service account has
no permission, though.
So what we have to do is we
have to generate an IAM policy.
Here I'm using
TerraForm's data source
to generate an IAM policy
that grants the editor
role to my service account, the
service account I just created.
And it's granting me owner
role over the project,
so I'll be able to be an owner.
And you can specify this binding
and these roles multiple times
to create different memberships.
You can get as fine
grained as you like,
and we saw a lot of examples
earlier of fine grained IAM
permissions.
And then lastly, we have
to upload that policy
to Google Cloud.
So we create an IAM policy,
we assign it to our project,
and we give it that policy data.
So now we've templatized
and programmatically created
a project with a
service account,
with the APIs we needed, all in
a single configuration format.
And this could be
across multiple clouds.
What you're seeing here
with this dollar curly
brace syntax is TerraForm's
interpolation syntax.
TerraForm builds a
graph under the hood
by using this
interpolation syntax.
So it'll parallelize
these operations
and create these resources
as fast as possible.
So if you're
creating 10 projects
and your quota allows
for you to have
10 projects created
simultaneously,
TerraForm will do that for you.
If you have a big huge
quota, because you're
someone like the Broad
Institute where you're
creating lots and
lots of projects,
you can create all
of those in parallel.
So provisioning times can be
as low as five to 10 minutes
for some of these resources.
You can also manage
these changes over time.
So if this project
changes, maybe you
want to update the name of it.
You want to change the service
account or the IAM policy.
You change it in the config.
You check it into
source control.
You get the pull request
approval workflow.
Then you apply those
changes to production,
and TerraForm handles
the diff for you.
And then lastly, this
isn't new to TerraForm,
this is something that
has existed for a while--
the ability to manage resources.
But within those
projects, you can now
specify that you want to
resource to live inside
of a particular project.
So here I'm creating
a compute instance,
and I'm saying this compute
instance lives in the project
that I just created.
So that TerraForm demo
project I just created,
we're dropping this
resource in there.
And if we had used
account attribute,
we would be able to
create this resource
in every single
project that we create,
allowing us to build
something like a training
environment or
ephemeral environments
for staging QA, dev,
whatever it might be.
So the goal here,
like the vision,
is to enable reproducible,
isolated, and codified
environments, regardless
of your cloud provider,
your multi-cloud, or your
hybrid cloud situation.
When we enable the ability to
capture infrastructure as code,
we get all of the benefits
that application developers
have had for years, while
we get the reproducibility,
the multi-cloud and the
hybrid-cloud approaches,
that allow us to be highly
scalable and highly agile
in today's multi-cloud
environments.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RAE WANG: Thank you, Seth.
And this brings us to
the end of our talk.
Just to summarize,
over the last hour
we went through how to use
IAM roles and permissions
to achieve the principle
of least privilege.
Using resource hierarchy to
both have central control
and delegate autonomy
to independent teams.
Org policies can allow
admin to set guardrails
around the flexibilities,
and automation
is key for scalability
and repeatability.
And finally, using
open source tools,
you can leverage of
these capabilities
but customized for
your own environments.
So this is the slide
for your photo needs.
It's a summary of all the
launches we have mentioned
and where to learn more.
We have a few minutes left,
so we could do some questions.
There are two microphones
in the middle.
We're also going to be at the
meet a PM send box afterwards,
so if you want to come and chat
in detail that can work, too.
OK.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]